angela on the way back from the strip
club
you were talking in the car and you said
that your age
is a problem why do you think even after
michael married you
that age is going to be an issue in your
relationship
because uh marty you know 54 gonna marry
a 32 year old man and for you to look at
other younger women weighing my presence
it makes me feel like maybe everybody's
you know at that time maybe everybody's
right maybe i shouldn't be marrying a
younger man
because obviously he can't even look at
me in public instead of looking at other
women
i i might thinking god i'm getting ready
to marry this man and he just made me
feel like [ __ ]
michael you had a chance to defend
angela's honor and everything
insecurities that she had against you
you had a moment in time to step
up and say no angela let's go home let's
make pizza
well i tried to be okay michael sit
there
and then me and joe's talking to him and
michael
pissed me off thinking about it he looks
between me and joe watching the girl and
he doesn't know that we see him i mean
he knows we're looking at him that's
what you gulp snake over here
that's sneaky michael nikki
michael what do you have to say for
yourself
well listen let me finish he has a
good-looking friend
great so i sat there and i said watch
michael i said i'm going to get his
attention one way or
another so i started dancing just with
his rings we're on our vip
and his friend was getting in and
getting it and i said yep i'm going to
make michael jealous
he was too busy enjoying me dancing with
his friends so he could get a glare out
of his eye like this
at the girl's cooter
[Laughter]
michael did you see angela dancing with
your friend dre
at the club yeah i was right there i
mean it's not it's nothing because i i
trust my friend
it's nothing because i trust both of
them so um
larissa would you mind if eric got a lap
dance in front of you in a strip club
i don't mind because the girls just care
about the men's money
so they are not doing a left dancing
eriky
because they think that he's handsome
it's just about
money she would know because she's a
[ __ ] stripper
shut up they go make him again he would
be there
no he would not
you